hello there YouTube
I am John Oliver host of last week
tonight we're on hiatus at the moment
but like a psychotic ex we're still
sending you videos from time to time to
remind you what you're missing you could
be having all this right now all this
all of this you could be having right
now for you anyway anyway I think I just
proved the opposite of my point but the
point is it's Thanksgiving and I'm here
to discuss perhaps the strangest
Thanksgiving tradition no not sitting
through a Detroit Lions game I'm talking
of course about turkey pardoning each
year the president pardons one turkey
who then presumably moves to Mexico to
live with Tim Robbins like they promised
each other but there is there is
something for a found Lee strange about
a president making a show of pardoning
one Turkey to mark a holiday on which
everyone the president included consumes
an estimated 46 million birds that the
whole thing is so strange
if we're going to pardon one turkey we
should pardon them all or we should put
them all on trial which which would
which would have literally be a little
difficult because getting a jury of
their peers is nearly impossible but
they do not and will not respond to
summonses and also more importantly it
will be an open-shut case because let's
be honest here every single turkey is
guilty specifically guilty of having
delicious bird parts that should be
serving time in the prison of my mouth
in fact I issue this challenge to
President Obama and all future
presidents if you want the world to
respect you just once show up at a White
House turkey pardoning with a cleaver at
administer that justice these birds so
clearly desire we'll be back in February
happy
get to talking